do you know the Justin do you know the
candy store analogy can you tell us yeah
I've heard Tate say it before
um so basically the way I've heard him
explain it I've never used it but
a man starts his life off at the bottom
of a mountain and he fights his ass off
and he gets hit by rocks and he gets
torn up in his ass handed to him and he
gets beat up and he falls down the
mountain has to start over goes bankrupt
he finally fights and fights and fights
and Claws away and he gets to the top of
the mountain and he gets into the candy
shop and he eats his first piece of
candy and they tell him that's the only
piece he can have
and generally a man that's done all of
that work is going to be like [__] you
I'm gonna take over the whole store
because very very very few men will ever
get up that mountain it's called the one
percent for a reason and it is a dog
fight
and that's what he's referring to it's
the thing that drives him in now there's
a lot of men out there that'll say oh
that's no using it as a dating strategy
any man
that could
love his wife tuck his kids in at night
be a good man provide for his entire
family be there as a father be a
provider be the hero for his family and
sleep with a couple women every now and
then would do it and anybody that says
otherwise a liar
straight up and and look I know that
sucks and it's not fair and it's
completely not fair but it is the
reality of the world and I think
sometimes when we talk about these
subjects we get lost between the
realities of the world and the Motions
because I know it I know it hurts it
does but it is absolutely true
wow
[Laughter]
just think of that
silence
I've done oh no not to a certain extent
speaking to the mic
their silence agrees with me they don't
have silence agrees that's what I was
going to say yeah their silence agrees
with me and look man I'm sorry
yeah and I get it and and like I said
before if I could pay a million dollars
to cut it off
I actually would I would actually cut it
off I think it's a waste of time
it will haunt a man it is in us just in
US
oh yeah it is it's in us all it's in
every one of us it's just it's just the
fact that a lot of men don't want to
climb that mountain yeah and so they'll
trade off things that they don't
actually want to do to get some piece of
candy
but the men that really want to hustle
want the whole [__] store and
generally that's the man that you're
going to admire and look up to because
he has ambition he has Drive in his life
he's a hard worker you believe in him
and most of all you trust him to take
care of you yeah that's all I'm saying
and I don't mean to be disrespectful but
I genuinely want you to hear me
because I fear that if young women that
are young and beautiful like you girls
are are taking advice from older women
that are not happy you are going to find
yourself in that same position I'm
saying it look as as heated as it got
I'm saying this out of love not not to
put you down I genuinely believe it
and I'm also not manipulating you
because I'm not trying to get with any
of you I'm going to get on a plane in a
couple days you know what I'm saying but
please let me leave this with you or
watch it again
any man that could would
I often say I'm not doing anything that
any other man would not do if he could
all right I love you all
I'm curious did any of you change your
opinion on cheating after listening to
him or after having this conversation I
hate that it's called cheating in the
first place because because the cheating
is a triggering part you know like if he
sets you down
like like pretty teeth said
you know she's like I wouldn't like it
but I would appreciate the truth yeah
it's the deceit that really is gonna
upset you because he's killing himself
for you he loves you more than anything
you take a bullet for you and the slags
on the side dude he don't even want him
in his bed at night
he's in love with you
yeah because it's you know how you guys
get emotional for no reason men are like
yeah so are you saying it's just like an
ego stroke no it's not an ego no that's
the point it's not about ego at all it's
not about ego at all like men that sleep
with women just to feel better about
themselves are super insecure yeah
you're lacking something right they're
lacking something no no it is more like
it's more like this primal thing inside
of you that will not get out of your
[__] head so is it Primal or is it
lacking something no no it's Primal it's
completely Primal does the fact that 8
000 years ago 17 women reproduced for
every one man does that mean anything to
you does that show at all that it's
primal
that always in history there's always
been more women reproducing for men I
think historically yeah but like so if
I'm crying we try and adapt like where
humans were you know creatures of
adaptation like I would try my best to
adapt if I didn't if something didn't
sit sit right with me but okay so so if
in modern society we're going back to
that like we're trending more towards
sharing men
I don't even like to share my food so
the best move I'm not sure
you're wrong you're wrong you have again
because we spoke about you've been in
situationships so you were sharing a guy
you're sharing guys right now but we're
beating a dead horse right you're all
sharing guys right now I'm not sharing a
new one yeah well we keep going back to
the same we keep coming back to the same
point because you guys whenever whenever
Justin whenever Justin makes the or
somebody makes the point and says well
no Matt this is how men are wide this is
how they're programmed these are the
things that they want then somebody on
the couch or wherever says um oh but not
all of them like like you did and it's
kind of like but no but we keep we keep
beating the same horse they they do all
want to do it they or they they are all
programmed not all of them necessarily
will act on it but that's partly down to
okay there's gonna be a few unicorns who
aren't going to act on it because
they're super amazing whatever guys I
don't know but I think so repercussions
are scared yeah yeah probably yes but
for the most part for the most part
they're not going to act on it because
then they don't have the ability to
because they're not high enough in the
food chain okay the guys are at the top
they all are going to act on it and
that's just how it is it's also
character as well right yeah I know you
think sorry go on it's also a character
like I think I can personally relate
because at some point you have a
connection that's distinct enough with
someone that it takes a long time for
that urge to come back yeah she'll come
back though sure oh yeah about at about
18 months probably yeah I'm not gonna
lie even for me I'll be like you know
what I could like really Vibe with
someone like she's one in a million
she's got chat we're cool but I part of
me knows that in like in like a year
maybe two some people been together for
20 years I know eventually
two becomes one why don't you think like
that but I I know I like that that's one
of the reasons I didn't have relation
when I was younger because I thought I
don't want to do that I don't mess
someone up but I realize bro I'm always
it's just human nature it's novelty yeah
I've tried to fix myself in my 20s I
thought something was wrong with me and
I thought I was all [__] up and I
hated myself for a long time yeah I
broke up with Miss Louisiana in college
because I like I felt like I couldn't do
it and I didn't want to be a piece of
[__] and I wouldn't try to pray about it
and do all this church stuff and I
couldn't defined it was just a pattern
that would not leave me in and I was I
was leaving women that I loved was that
because there's something too if like
yourself no not at all it was literally
what I'm telling you I wouldn't lie to
you and let me let me nail it home with
this
it could be an ugly woman
ugly woman I could eat for me it's
hungry and horny to a man it's pretty
much the same thing I gotta stress this
to you no do you know what I do agree
with that like I do agree that it's
nothing to do with the looks it doesn't
matter is she I don't bro does it
breathe like men are disgusting that is
the first thing that I actually 100 like
agree with you on she could be the
ugliest girl in the world but he's still
gonna do well it's like the old thing
it's like it's like the old thing you
know you've got steak at home but
sometimes you just fancy going out for a
McDonald's you know what I mean and
that's just the reality yeah
it's not even about cheap it's just
about different and it's like this thing
is people people will demonize it and
act like you know was this more bro it
is wired into US it almost comes out of
us in a way and and again I cannot
stress this enough if I could pay to get
rid of that feeling I would absolutely
do it 100 I guess it's nice it's not
nice that's the wrong word but I guess
it's like a a bit more a better feeling
for us girls to know that he's sat there
saying that if he could get rid of it he
would you know what I mean it's
counterproductive yeah
it's not like a one do you know what I
mean it's like if you're saying that you
could I'd get rid of this if I I would
pay to get rid of it yeah see that's
reassurance for us girls but you don't
probably think that you're reassuring is
saying that that's just something that
you personally believe
for us girls that is reassurance
wants to do that I don't know I think
modern women don't really hear these
things though I think it's hard for us
there's not many men that can say it and
get away with it there's no spaces to be
honest yeah I think Pearly things is a
safe space in some ways right that's
controversial
but it's not but it's not but let me
tell you something else about you guys I
have a platform right women see my
content women or women that I see will
see me say this and they'll see me
anyway
you understand what I'm saying like yeah
I'm not of course I'm not trying to
bully y'all like I have this like many
many many men cannot say what I'm saying
and get away oh yeah and so
I know you're not used to hearing it and
and for that reason I'm trying to be
graceful right now because I feel like
earlier it got heated but truly if I
could get rid of it yeah if I could get
rid of it I truly mean it up here
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible